[musique]
Je suis un migrant de Donetsk
J'ai quitté Donetsk en 2014 avec
le début d'événements désagréables pour tout le monde
connus de cette époque, je n'y suis jamais allé
c'est-à-dire ce qui se passe maintenant
s'est produit il n'y a pas si longtemps à Kiev
je fais le tour, j'en ai déjà vu à Donetsk
Et
m'a inspiré, m'a donné de l'espoir
que j'ai déjà perdu en général
en général, tout en bas, pour ainsi dire
état émotionnel
alors je suis venu ici et je suis allongé ici
pendant quatre jours presque c'est tout moi
satisfait très à l'aise très gentil
personnel compréhensif
[musique]
dis donc il y en a et quelque part la moitié
des patients qui, mais ce ne sera pas le cas
probablement une spécialité du cou, ce sera
alors oh, j'ai résumé ça, qui était assis
le code du sous-sol sera le fossé du corps de Komi là-bas
à partir de quelques semaines par mois tel
et puis ils le transforment en sous-sol
au pied de la rovka, puis ils viennent à Kiev
où, eh bien, pour ainsi dire, les jours où l'on perd sa place
résidence et maintenant ils sont dans une nouvelle ville
en fait plus courbé car toujours en retard
nouveau mais je pense que ce programme est fait pour moi
aider à renforcer et
améliorer votre état émotionnel
parce que eh bien, pourquoi encore une fois
j'ai peur mais je n'ai aucune raison
[musique]